you're looking for an attractive man
with a lot of testosterone i just
accepted this
party actually in hungary it was a safe
party
speaking of attraction let's talk about
let's talk about it it was for eric's
story by the way this next story if you
don't like
crude stories skip this one here but i
think you're gonna you're gonna
this this is not a spoof this is a real
story of what happened yesterday
it was the most number one trending
story on business insider and it has
nothing to do with business
it's the number one story he was taking
care of business all right he was but
it's the number one
inside business insider trending story
yesterday an anti-gay
hungarian politician has resigned
after being caught by the police fleeing
a 25-man orgy through a window
you have to realize like that's like a
movie that's like that doesn't make any
sense let me read that one more time
an anti-gay hungarian politician
has resigned after being caught by the
police fleeing a 25-man orgy through a
window
an ally of hungarian prime minister
victor orban
resigned from the european parliament
after attending what was described a
25-minute origin brussels
joseph sazar quit as an emep
on sunday and later uh said he was
present at a private party
the police found him and 24 other naked
men at gathering including diplomats and
local reports said
he played a key role in the urban
government crackdown on lgbtq community
rights in hungary
a source closer to the investigation
told politico that officers
were called after complaining about a
nighttime disturbance i deeply regret
violating the covet restrictions it was
irresponsible on my part
i'm ready to stand for the final final
uh find that course
he announced his resignation and
obviously the rest is history adam i
think it's important for you to take it
when we were going down because kai
usually makes the topics that we i
thought you guys were pulling a joke
what the hell i seriously thought they
were like pulling i'm like this is this
is a real story
this is ridiculous so i thought kai was
was pranking us so a couple things let
me just start off with the old seinfeld
episode like and he was gay not that
there's anything wrong with that
not there's anything wrong with that
unless you are a
anti-gay marriage politician hungry
who's secretly in ma
involved in a gay orgy a gorgie and
um this is hypocrisy at its finest and
then i kind of dig a little deeper you
know because
you know for some reason i was like i
gotta know more bro um
he he said he said look you know i
violated covet restrictions my bad
you know you were there tom you know he
said well look you know i
i had an ecstasy pill in my pocket it
might have been i'm like listen dude
you're screwing up listen buddy i
partied in south beach
i may or may not have taken an xd pill
in my day okay
what happens is when you take an ecstasy
pill you go out you go to the dance
party you have a good time
you know you you meet some chicks you
don't end up at a gorgey
okay that's just not so don't blame it
on the xd
you know excessive pill homie you're a
gay dude who hates yourself
and you're fighting against anti-gay
marriage in hungary of all places
and it's just hypocrisy out of the
window jumped out of the window
naked naked jumps out of the window
naked is this real life right now
and meanwhile to be honest he is
fighting against
gay rights meanwhile he's involved in a
naked hungarian gang bang you know i'm
going to stay with my initial theory the
stay in your lane you know just like
bitcoin
i left it to the experts or geez i'm
gonna leave it to the two experts here
all right so you guys handled that
perfectly but i will say this kai pull
up the story we did on vt post yesterday
writing these headlines i never had more
joint satisfaction than using the words
i mean you don't get to do that every
day my country's out of control at least
biden and trump aren't having origins
with two dozen other people like this
goof in hungary
that's what he looks like yeah you got
that
so here's the question here's the
question here's the most you know
entertaining when i go to the party sure
what is that
mario where you at bro no this is the
question this is the question how many
of
have you ever had an embarrassing moment
that happens to one of your friends and
you see him for the first time and the
moment you see me got that smirk on your
face you know that moment
wait you know what it's even worse if
you were involved in the embarrassment
you showed up with your friend you know
he's doing the millionaires
so so then yeah so you see him so you
see him so you see him yeah
i mean imagine you're his brother you're
you know what do you do when you see him
like dude anything what's the first
thing you've done
[Music]
because this dude's sitting on a gold
mine i mean telling his story
a book or something my god he's not
sitting on a globe he's sitting on
something else but you know it's
it's uh it's a um but it's one of those
things when you're so
anti-something i don't know these people
you got something going on behind the
closet you know in the closet
something's going on here
so you can't even say i hope somebody
prays i wonder if he's married though
you know i was
this close to not including it because
it just sounds so absurd
adam he's married he's married he's he's
married to a woman oh a wife he has a
female wife
no he's married no he is what is the
married
the wow he comes home to the wife what
is she
how'd you like my line he has a female
wife female wife you gotta you know
the wife is probably like i've known
this entire time she's gonna know
no wonder you can't you know
but i got this excellent doesn't work
his wife's going to tell him hey you can
go on a helicopter ride with uh onassis
go have fun
[Music]
go